[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il y a un rapport qui divise les
économistes c'est celui entre dette et
croissance la dette et elle l'a mis où
l'ennemi de la croissance il y a 10 ans
de professeur de finance américain qui
est Carmen Reinhardt publier un
best-seller cette fois c'est différent
lui siècle de folie financière en
analysant la récurrence avec laquelle
les pays riches comme les pays pauvres
s'endette jusqu'à ce que crise
financière s'ensuive il posait une règle
simple passé un certain seuil de dette
90 % du PIB une décroissance inéluctable
s'enclenche la dette serai donc les
nuits de la croissance mais tu étais
remise en cause par d'autres
universitaire surtout que la situation
aujourd'hui comprenez poste covit des
postes quoi qu'il en coûte n'est plus la
même qu'il y a 10 ans prenez la dette
française selon les dernières prévisions
elle devrait atteindre à la fin de ses
115, 3 % du PIB puis descendre à 113,5
pourcents en 2022 et pourtant même si on
sait que nous sommes en plein rebond
économique après une récession de plus
de 8 % en 2020 la croissance prendrai
les 7 pourcents cette année selon l'OCDE
encore et attendre 4,2 pourcents en 2022
la règle des 90 % de dette publique en
rangeant de la décroissance semble donc
un peu bancal dans ce contexte poste
covit selon Michel Gérard d'un
professeur à l'Université de Genève il
faudrait en plus de la dette porter
attention à la charge de la dette sur
qu'un pays doit dépenser chaque année
pour rembourser sa dette temps que la
charger batterie et même s'il était
massive comme au Japon par exemple la
croissance pourrais continuer ce serait
en fait la conjonction du niveau
d'endettement et de la charge d'intérêt
qu'il faudrait considérer et pas
seulement la dette